FTX said you know we're built by Traders  for Traders and Sam Bragg that they only  charge like three basis points trading  fee and he was 30 times cheaper than  coinbase or much cheaper than binance so  he's stealing customers off of the other  crypto exchanges by in essence offering  near free Trading he's not trying to  make money off the trading he's trying  to actually get the assets on his  platform because once he had the assets  on his platform he basically used FTX  like his own personal piggy bank it's  like there's 10 billion dollars there  everybody else is going to get wiped out  if uh if their margin positions trade  down 20 percent for a minute  except Alameda Alameda has God mode they  never get margin called